[Música]
la vida
es la historia que decidimos contarnos
buenos días me llamo mariana y nací dos
veces
en noviembre del 2008 estaba por
terminar mi primer semestre en la
universidad un año después
mi vida había cambiado por completo esta
soy yo internada en un centro de
rehabilitación después de una complicada
cirugía
todavía me acuerdo el día que me dijeron
que tenía un tumor en el cerebro y vamos
mi mamá y yo en la camioneta llorando de
camino al hospital
en medio de nuestro llanto
y algo sucedió en mí decidí que no iba a
asustarme y dejé de llorar
lo primero que me acuerdo haber pensado
después de la cirugía fue no me morí
me acuerdo que las enfermeras se
desesperaban conmigo en las noches
porque no me quería dormir trataba con
todas mis fuerzas de mantenerme
despierta porque me daba miedo que si se
daba en los ojos no iba a volver a
despertar
en realidad si tuve mucho miedo de
morirme entonces de dónde salió esta
fuerza para dejar de llorar
de niña siempre fui muy tímida la ned
del salón digamos que no fue invitada a
todas las fiestas de 15 años pero sí
pasé a recoger mi diploma de primer
lugar enfrente de toda la secundaria con
los pantalones del informe de bebés
nunca me describe como alguien muy
fuerte
o en el fondo siempre quise serlo ese
día cuando iba en la camioneta con mi
mamá dejé de llorar porque frente a la
incertidumbre de la mala noticia que nos
había dado el doctor decidí que
finalmente había llegado mi oportunidad
de ser fuerte hoy puedo decir que entre
muchos altos y bajos he salido adelante
de tres cirugías años de rehabilitación
y las secuelas que siguieron
cuando regrese a la uni después de mi
tiempo internada todavía estaba en silla
de ruedas pelona y usaba tanque de
oxígeno
tuve que obligarme a hablar con mis
compañeros porque pensaba que si me
veían en la silla y con el tanque no se
me iban a que hacer acá
pensé que me iban a vestir raro
con el tiempo fui aprendiendo que verme
como llegada era lo último en la mente
de mis compañeros me decían que era muy
fuerte y cambiaban de optimismo en mi
actitud ante la vida
pero mi optimismo mi actitud ante la
vida pesimista siempre fue una de las
palabras que use para describir
pesimista tímida miedosa etcétera ahora
que lo veo me prospectiva me pregunto
cómo puede ser que después de todo lo
que viví me sigue habiendo como aquella
niña miedosa
mi vida ha ido cambiando poco a poco
desde que la historia que decidí contar
me empezó a ser una de fuerza
pero esa historia no ha sido fácil de
escribir
luego hacemos unos años atrás cuando
todavía estaba en terapia intensiva
todas cableadas como bien me dijo una
vez además de tubo catéter y demás
también tenía una sonda de gastrostomía
con la que me alimentaba una de las
secuelas de la cirugía fue que perdí mi
capacidad para discutir no podía tragar
nada por lo tanto no podía comer por la
boca
por eso necesitaba una sonda para comer
deben haber pasado semanas en el
hospital sin que viera nada de comida
hasta que por fin un día una enfermera
llego a mi cuarto con un bote de webber
y tuvo una pastilla y la mezcla en una
cuchara con el bebé
me acuerdo de la emoción que sentí
cuando me di cuenta que finalmente iba a
probar algo con sabor
cuando una enfermera me dio la cucharada
trate de tragarme lo que tenía con todas
mis fuerzas de at&t pero como no me lo
pude pasar salió volando para todos
lados
la enfermedad de las cosas y se las
llevó y esa es la última vez que vi algo
de comida
durante mis casi seis meses internada
en ese momento no lo sabía pero no poder
comer por la boca es algo en lo que me
iba a tener que acostumbrar la condición
se llama disfagia y todavía vivo con
ella todavía no puedo tragar nada
todavía me alimento por medio de una
zona
verme al espejo con una sonda en el
abdomen es las cosas que más trabajo me
ha costado asimilar
vea todos a mi alrededor comiendo y sabe
que yo no puedo hacerlo
de las que más trabajo me ha costado
aceptar
al principio sólo comía en mi casa
porque no quería que nadie viera mi
sonda iba a la uni tomaba unas frases y
me besaba a mi casa como la nueva ni
salidas al cine oa cualquier otro lugar
alrededor de las horas en las que tenía
que estar en mi casa para pasarme la
comida cuando empecé a meter más
materias en la uni el equipo de
mantenimiento me prestó una de sus
bodegas para que comiera y con la
privacidad que en ese momento necesitaba
íbamos a clases y cuando todos mis
compañeros se iban a la café yo me iba a
mi bodega a comer
me tomó mucho tiempo animarme a comer en
público porque pensaba que si la gente
me veía con mi sonda me iba a efe
lo mismo que pensaba con las ideas de
verdad se acuerda
pero así como ese primer día de clases
me obligué a hablar con mis compañeros
cuando por fin decidí sentarme a comer
en la café me obligué a centrarme con
mis amigas y actuar como si nada
mi mamá siempre me dijo la gente te va a
tratar de acuerdo la actitud que tú
proyectos
si te portas segura la gente te va a
tratar con seguridad
pero si te portas así en figura la gente
te va a tratar con inseguridad
hasta la fecha nadie nunca me ha hecho
sentir incómoda mientras me paso la
comida
darme cuenta de que nadie me vio feo ni
por tener una silla de ruedas ni por
usar una sonda me enseñó que como me
decía mi mamá tengo el poder de decidir
la imagen que quiero proyectar ante los
demás
pero me faltaba aprender algo mucho más
importante también tengo el poder de
decidir cómo me veo yo
lo que tenía que cambiar no era lo que
los demás pensaban de mí sino lo que yo
pensaba de mí misma
nadie me estaba viendo feo
la única que se estaba viendo a sí
a ello
me vuelvo a preguntar entonces cómo
puede ser que después de todo lo que
viví
me sigue habiendo como aquella niña
miedosa
a nuestros modos personales son la
percepción que tenemos de nosotros
mismos lo que nos decimos que somos o no
somos la falta de fe en nuestras propias
capacidades
no vayan a que que ha pedido todas estas
cosas yo sola me encantaría poder
decirles que toda esta sabiduría viene
100% de mi cerebro pero la verdad es que
el 50 por ciento viene de los regaños
que me dan y mamá y el otro 50% de los
que me dan ni siquiera raquel hace poco
más de un año decidí regresar un proceso
de terapia porque bueno vamos a hacer un
estos aquí y admitir que para procesar
lo que sucede en nuestras mentes muchas
veces necesitamos ayuda
en mi caso ayuda profesional
una de las sesiones de terapia raquel me
preguntó qué fue lo que te hizo salir
adelante
de la cirugía y de todo lo que siguió
después automáticamente le contesté que
saldría adelante gracias al apoyo de mi
familia
pero no comencé a ver que con esa
respuesta me insistía en que además de
eso había algo más
siguiendo su recomendación empecé a
buscar adentro de mí
desempolvando recuerdos del pasado sobre
todo de antes de que me peguen
los voy a dejar con una última anécdota
a pesar de considerarme una niña tímida
siempre me gustó salir en las zona
mímicas de la escuela en todas cuando
iba en cuarto de primaria pp con mis
amigas una coreografía para la que mes
la canción no es obsesión de onda
vaselina
un clásico
la tarjeta sucedió el día de la que mes
cuando no llegó ninguna de las amigas
con las que tenía que bailar
estaba llorando tras bambalinas cuando
llegó la señora mi maestra con una
propuesta para mí
porque no bailas tú sola
se acordaron que se había platicado de
niña siempre fue muy tímida la cne del
salón una niña así claramente no se te
veía a bailar sola en frente de todos en
la que mes
pero si baile
a lo mejor después de la historia de la
sonda esta anécdota le son un poco
insignificante
pero para mí no lo es
no lo es porque cuando veo esa foto no
veo a una niña miedosa
veo una niña valiente
resulta sé que ocho años después me
estoy dando cuenta que esa niña miedosa
de la que hablaba nunca existió
esa línea que decidió ser valiente en la
camioneta de camino al hospital y deja
de llorar es la misma línea que decidió
ser valiente y baila sola en frente de
todos en la que mes
después de mucho tiempo finalmente lo
entendí
esta experiencia no me hizo fuerte
la fuerza ya la tenía adentro
pero nunca había sabido verdad
me tomo el aprender a dm a través de los
ojos de otros para darme cuenta que esta
experiencia no me cambio
cambio de forma en cómo me veo
después de meses de trabajo en terapia
finalmente dijo la respuesta que buscaba
la piel ese día que me preguntó qué fue
lo que te hizo salir adelante
y fui yo
mi determinación
mi perseverancia
mi fuerza
claro que todavía me dan miedo muchas
cosas como las arañas que están en
backstage
todavía me desespero todavía me frustro
no soy yo muchas veces por tonterías
pero es que me conozco como alguien
fuerte sé que tengo permitido tropezar m
porque me voy a poder levantar
cuántos de ustedes
están atrapados en esa misma historia
que yo estaba atrapada
cuántos de ustedes se días solitos y no
se levantan porque se definen con
etiquetas que los limitan
porque no han sabido veces con esos
otros ojos
la vida
es la historia que decidimos contarnos
qué historias se van a contar hoy
muchas gracias
[Música]
o no